well let's get more on the seizing of
two US navy boats by Iran national
security analyst arash arash joins me
from Los Angeles good morning Arash no
one gets the sense that neither sides
particularly want this incident to
escalate do you think that's a fair
reading of the situation well I can say
that the US Navy is and its personnel
its sailors and officers are trained to
show a great deal of restraint they will
they never want to be the aggressor
person situation like this now one a
rigid inflatable whole boat and I'm
assuming this is one of those rih fees a
small vessel usually manned by a number
of enlisted personnel and a junior
officer that is used mainly for
patrolling for security reasons in a
Persian Gulf or for psychological ops or
before handing out flyers to you know to
fishermen to local vessels when a vessel
like this comes under threat you should
we should wait for all the facts come
out to see why no one engaged the
Iranian IRGC vessels and any sort of
hostile you know firing or returning
fire but you know as we know they showed
a lot of restraint they let the vessels
to be boarded they let the last vessels
to be towed into Iranian territory and
as we know now from what the department
said the fence has said one or perhaps
both of these vessels were disabled and
we're waiting for repairs to come now on
the Iranian side this is IRGC area of
operation the Persian Gulf and the
Strait of Hormuz while the government of
President Hassan rouhani and his foreign
minister mr. javad zarif are not
interested in escalating tensions with
the west war perhaps with the United
States I can't say the same thing with a
degree of certainty about IPL a hominid
the supreme leader or the IRGC the
Islamic Revolutionary Guard Corps that
is definitely one of the more hardline
elements within the power structure in
Iran so I rush how is it being greeted
in America I mean it comes just weeks
after Iran launched a rocket test near
US warships and boats that were passing
through the Strait of Hormuz it's not
being viewed positively at all
especially given the fact that in less
than two hours the president is going to
deliver
for his very last State of the Union
address speech in which he is probably
going to highlight some of his most
successful legacy points and his
achievements one of which according to
the administration is the Iran nuclear
deal the Iran nuclear deal that the
administration has invested a great deal
of political capital on while we see now
that again there are elements within the
Iranian government that are at the very
least are not acting in a friendly
manner there is a possibility that in
the past few weeks these hardliners you
know after I talking to Saudi embassy in
Tehran and now launching missiles in the
Persian Gulf Strait of Hormuz so close
to American ships and vessels in the
Persian Gulf and now capturing or as
some in Iran would like to put it
rescuing these sailors and maybe they
are trying to create obstacles in the
path of this so-called moderate
government of mr. rouhani and the
doctors re if the foreign minister but
again it's not being you positively the
president was hoping in a steamer hoping
to get these sailors released as soon as
possible before daylight and the Persian
Gulf so he could go to Congress with
sort of good news but that's not going
to happen most likely again it's going
to be interesting to see what the
Republican opposition would say in terms
of president's foreign policy legacy
especially with the Iran deal and
tension of hostilities between Iran and
the United States of America Arash you
speak of these hardliners how much
influence do they have within Iran and
indeed on iranian foreign policy well
plenty and that's just saying in a
nutshell plenty what we got to keep in
mind is that Iran is a country of me no
paradoxes for that matter on the one
hand an election was how a moderate
government came to power to try to
address some of these issues economic
issues that were directly linked to us
sanctions and global sanctions because
of Iran's nuclear program and its
nuclear ambitions on the other hand
dryer elements within the Islamic
Republic of Iran that are not interested
at all in reaching a rapprochement with
the with the West for ideological
reasons and for economic reasons now
Michael a hominid the Supreme Leader
he's also the commander
chief he was never very positive about
new movie a rapport mom with the west
and the IRGC the Islamic Revolutionary
Guard guard guard court reports directly
to him and there's a reason why it's
them and not the regular Iranian
military that is in charge of protecting
Iran's warriors in the Persian Gulf in
the Strait of Hormuz because they view
the Persian Gulf a sort of the American
lake and they are very much threatened
by US presence in the Gulf of providing
security so hardliners do yield plenty
of power and as we're going into
elections in the next few weeks in Iran
that will try to curtail rouhani and his
you know crowd influence and popularity
but they do have plenty of power with
the military intelligence and especially
the course of apparatus of the country